[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Crockett and I'm the
Astronomy writer at science news in 2017
will be learning about new things than
our own solar system to the center of
the galaxy out to galaxies billions of
light years away one of the things I'm
looking forward to in 2017 is
astronomers figuring out where fast
radio bursts are coming from these are
these really big blasts of radio waves
that appear to be coming from other
galaxies but we have no idea what's
causing them primer is getting really
close to narrowing down where these
things are coming from by detecting them
at one telescope and in quickly catching
it with another telescope and I've heard
some rumors that there might be some
really cool discoveries announcements
coming out pretty soon a bit closer to
home there's a project called the event
horizon telescope that's been running
for about a decade
what they're doing is linking together
radio telescopes around the world to
create one giant virtual telescope
that's about the size of the earth and
what they're hoping to do is actually
see the supermassive black hole it's
about 28,000 light-years away in the
center of the galaxy and we've never
mailed it actually see a black hole
before because well because they're back
they don't give off any light but what
they're looking for is actually light
that's being bent around it by its
immense gravity it's a phenomenally
difficult thing to do it's like trying
to see an orange on the surface of the
Moon the Juno mission is at Jupiter and
it's been there since July but now it's
gonna really start doing its regular
science mapping the interior of Jupiter
getting a 3d picture of what the biggest
planet in our solar system is like on
the inside
look how much water there is whether or
not there's a core that'll tell us a lot
about how Jupiter formed and that can
plus a lot of about how the rest of the
solar system forms and solar systems
throughout the galaxy but I think one of
the the coolest things going on in the
solar system this year is the end of the
Cassini mission at Saturn after almost
20 years in space and over a decade at
Saturn the missions coming to an end
spacecraft is gonna start going where
it's never gone before and it's guy
start repeatedly diving between the
Rings and the planets they as they fly
the Rings they're gonna spin the
spacecraft so that the big radio dish is
facing forward they're using that is
like a deflector shield and so if
anything from the Rings hits it it'll
bounce off the antenna and protect the
instruments behind it
so that when we get really close to
Saturn and see details they'd never seen
before but actually be able to figure
out just how massive the Rings are which
might tell them where they came from and
then in September the missions going to
end by deflecting and diving into the
atmosphere and the spacecraft will
plunge to its death making measurements
all the way down the reason they they're
ending it that way is actually to
protect the icy moons around Saturn
moves that we think have salt where
oceans beneath them
the Cassini may still carry some sort of
biological contamination on it and they
don't want to remotely risk our biology
getting into the oceans of Saturn's
moons so they're just going to toss the
spacecraft away into the planet it's
always a really cool here you're writing
about astronomy
we're always discovering new things and
I'm sure 2017 will be no different
you